foreign
is everyone good
oh I'm sorry about c-sharp I'll tell
later why okay
well
I hope right like it's it's good to have
this kind of conference right to meet
people and actually today I'm gonna show
you something that I I was not expert I
was actually researching and actually I
found some bug and then node.js score
and it was like no no it's not a bug
it's me doing something wrong so I'm
gonna go through this whole process okay
so uh
first of all all of this presentations
are already online so you should follow
me on Twitter I'm gonna publish there
and you can chat later as well if you
can please take pictures mention the
event mention myself this helps us a lot
with the work with bingoing all right
so
first of all I was just like you
attending some events I actually uh you
know write Brazil don't speak English
much as well so I was there struggling a
lot to learn English but I was with a
lot of people on the open source and
helping on the node.js core and some
collaborators and there were some
activities there to help you to get your
first comment there so collaborators
were just giving you some tasks easy
test I'm gonna show you the first one
but you know right there are a lot of
environment things and other kind of
stuff that you you might do a part of
the the whole thing so on this Workshop
you know I'm not a good photographer
right but this image means a lot for me
well this was actually what the taxi the
task I got it was just to switch the
test right you can see it was very
simple but for me it meant a lot because
I should follow the node.js style guide
I actually should a make the environment
work and a lot of other stuff well after
struggling a lot with this code I
finally got this email and was like your
name is now on the node.js card I was
like oh my God I'm gonna show it to my
mom now so this was really nice and for
everyone who finished it they gave a a
pin so this ping for me was like oh my
God this is so nice
well
this was like 2018 and I was since then
trying to find something nice to work on
the node.js car but I just gave up
because there were not much information
on the internet for me I was really
struggling a lot well but I'm talk to
you now about the book I found
I think you're gonna relate that you
know when you are sure
that you are making something like
you've done like 10 times and you're
like no I don't need Google I don't know
how to do this and actually it wasn't
working like I had no idea what's
working and actually it was a bug it
finally was a bug and I was able to try
finding it well let me introduce you
first what was the idea and then I
walked through that problem well first
of all the problem was using the child
process first of all how many of you are
back-end Developers
all right you from 10 developers who use
just npm wires were all affected by the
same bug but I'm gonna go through later
well in the node.js score you can use
charity processes to spin up other
processes you can actually uh run
parallel tasks and communicate with
other programs basic uh this is the goal
to make this work you should have two
files the first one is the child right
the the test that is going to execute in
background so here I'm just listening
for a message and I'm just sending a
message right away make sure that you
remember the logs on the child I have
message received on child and here in
the parents there are a lot of code
right but I'm just focused on this part
all this code is ecmascript so the whole
book is on ecmascript not require uh not
common JS but here I'm just spinning up
this file this program and listen to the
message and I'm just sending the message
to the child so the child is receiving a
message and the parent is singing and
receiving at the same time all right so
when I try to run this code I Was
preparing the classes and see I'm just
receiving the message on the parent
the child didn't receive anything I was
like oh my God no no it's not possible
what's going on here I've done this code
a lot but then I was like
what if I do some like work around I put
a set time out there and I was waiting
and then I received the message so I
figured maybe the the child process is
not ready yet to receive this message so
maybe this is a book but I was like no
no maybe it's just me doing some mistake
as always right Friday cold after 6 p.m
it's hard to think
well the way I thought how it was a
burden how this bug actually affected
all of you here when I started
researching I found a lot of issues open
on jest on my arcs and a lot of other
packages and people from like
maintainers saying no no this is not our
fault it's node.js they should fix it on
the node.js side it almost like oh my
God no one had fixed this yet so maybe I
should like try fixing it but I had no
idea so the whole point of this talk is
about commuting right it's not about
being specialist and not nothing like
I've I've helped I've had have a lot of
from these two people m is like one of
the best persons ever she actually uh
wrote a lot of popular modules on the
node.js core like worker threads C plus
plus crazy stuff I would say right and
rich is one of people of the the node.js
technical steering committee who helps
like choosing what is going on to the
node.js with the I would say the
bureaucratic part right so this it's
hard so I start talking to each other
about my ideas and actually my idea was
kind of introducing a new event
so when the sharing process is ready to
receive a message I would send it right
away I was like well it makes sense
using my mind however I was talking to
Anna and she said I have another idea
maybe you should just in queue the
message until you have some child
available right I was like oh this would
make more sense let me go through this
now the problem was I have the main
process and I have between the process
you have some Channel Hub right some
messages going back and forth I was
trying to send a message but the child
process wasn't ready yet so Anna's idea
was I would create like an in-memory
database some object there that is gonna
store all those messages and when we had
the child ready then this communication
Hub will get all the message cling the
messages and send to the child processes
and then when I try to send If the child
process is ready it was okay I was like
oh this is so much better than I thought
but it's good to know right so first of
all I was like okay I want some feedback
and I I actually wanna I wanna help
implemented this right so I wrote the
whole issue there but notice only the
first line the first line said I would
like to help fixing this bug you know
there are a lot of contributors there
that might fix this bug in like two
minutes 30 minutes right but I really
want I really like to go through and to
learn more how I could do this so the
community helped a lot and a lot of
people said yeah this is a bird go go
forward and try fixing this bug well the
first thing was to compile node.js
like have you ever tried to compile on
OJs it's like my machine back then
wasn't that good
so it took like two hours to compile and
every time I was changing some code it
must be compiled again I was like no no
no I'm doing something wrong here this
shouldn't be that hard so reading the
docs right we should do this read more
often I found some some ideas to
actually read our JS code from our uh
path right from our directory so I
waited for the whole hour I'll go
through some lunch and then it compiled
after this compilation I actually got to
the file like the child process I wrote
some code there and I actually executed
the node.js that the compilation process
just made it I was like oh it's working
then I changed again I was like oh very
nice and now I'm I can't remember right
oh very nice now I'm able to to try
working now I can print it out I can
debug it and I can test what's going on
right it's not that difficult anymore
well so I start coding a lot trying to
get some answers I try like reaching
Anna a lot I think I annoyed her a lot
too but she she didn't complain so it
was nice well the first thing I got to
the node.js process uh file and I was
like looking for the 200 or 2 000 lines
of code and then I found these two
messages two two functions right we have
handle message and emit so they go us if
there's no listening which is weight
saving a list and then we keep sending
so I said Grant here's the place I'm
gonna start notice that I didn't write
any code any test yet right I just I was
just trying to prove my concept back
then and then I would start creating the
test but look I created the list
very straightforward I was actually
trying to listen how many listeners I
had waiting for messages if there is no
no listeners there
or if it's like an internal message I
just figure that node.js talks to
himself for some way is like crazy but
that's fine and then if there is no no
one asking for Masters I would just add
to this function and make it work anyway
well look at the difference right before
one line after this whole uh New Logic
code
well the next step is actually when I
have someone trying to listen right when
I have a new listener I will actually
get those messages see if there is any
painting message and then I'll call that
admit function and then I will clear the
all the message notice that there are a
lot of
ugly code here like for many people but
this was just the first version right
then I'm gonna refactor and do this
better but back then I was like I want
to make this work my my idea must work
my proof of concept proof of concept
should work here
all right well
after this I came back to our our
preview example so now I have exactly
the same file that I had there and then
I tried working this and then I got this
message I was like oh my God and now it
worked now it worked now I can go
through try fixing uh submitting the pr
finally I do I did something that he
affected a lot of people right so this
is uh really nice so then I write the
test so here the test I'm doing
everything in a single file it's a
single file application
here I just get uh by the arguments so
if there's no argument I know that I
will call the pirate right so I'm just a
spin up a process send me a message and
actually I'm waiting for this message
once I have it I will just compare If
the message I sent was the same I
received not not that hard back then and
then here on the else I will just wait
for the message and send it back all
right the problem was the child wasn't
receiving in time look that there's no
set timeout anymore right oh very nice
all right so I ran all of the node.js
that suite and I break the node.js
everything was stopped working was like
oh my God no please what I'm gonna do
now I break all their tests right what
was working the node.js
but you know when we're working in any
kind of application we feel like oh we
it's too complex but most of the
problems we have we fix with f right I
was just checking if the property was
there if it was just keep going then I
ran my test again my actually my my
proof of Concepts I ran the test that
was failing and the whole test Suite
again and then 100 okay so I got through
on the docs and I was like what is the
next step but the code is working so
let's cheer up let's have some beer
right now some amazing well I came back
and I had to run some linking right to
check if my style guide was following uh
what node.js cares and I mean
it wasn't that good right 45 45 Euros
for people who was behind so I had to
fix one by one so I should have like
configured my vs code but that's fine it
worked and finally I opened the request
following the docs it's very
straightforward you you write a title
you you have a description and actually
you link all the references you had to
make this PR
all right now what's the worst part
right you submit and you you have the
syndrome right like oh my God I'm not
good enough my call my code is horrible
but it's still the testing was passing
so I was like oh man I mean they won't
close my PR because it's working right
it's ugly but it's working
well I got a lot of feedback and I think
this is the main point of working for
free on the open source you learn a lot
of stuff that you might like not have
seen in working with apis or create
applications right
in this case I was creating a public
field and I do just said well you could
use symbols to create private Fields I
was like oh yeah a lot of symbols are
right but yeah it was really nice uh
actually he was saying that I shouldn't
rely on the array iterator a radiator is
a global object that someone can mutate
and break the whole node.js so I
couldn't use the spread operator the
three dots right there and I had to use
reflex apply which is like like
utilitary from YouTube's on the node.js
to make the same thing well and for me
the most interesting one was James Nails
saying well this is a performance issue
you're gonna make the node.js very slow
because of this I didn't really know I
just changed the for loop from outside
the next stick to inside the next stick
I was like very nice then I was this is
kind of I think uh Ellie said on his
talk in her talk like we feel like when
people are questioning like they are the
the whole like the the owner of the
truth right but sometimes they're not
right sometimes they're just asking you
uh Anna just said okay James now said
okay but now we have another problem you
have the race condition it it could
happen that you're trying to read a
message that is not even on the node.js
yet and you have like undefined it's not
a fan oh yeah the classic and the finals
the adventure all right and then I got
this message again you are now on on a
version of the node.js and I was like
this is so amazing my PR got to the note
17 and I saw my name I would say I was
about to print it and putting up board
like a huge board on my wall because it
was so amazing
yeah I really like it this is really
really nice
but you know right when we are working
with programming in general you know
that's not that easy right sometimes and
suddenly the pr was closed and someone
just made this question oh well you
fixed on 17 but the current version is
14 will this be fixed and 14. I was like
oh my God yeah I should try doing and I
do that said oh you we are Community you
should go there try to backport basic
copy paste the code to run on the branch
on the 14 version I was like no way I'm
gonna do this right I did there and I'm
gonna do it again
so here I did the same idea I did the
back part there copy paste and now I
thought this was way better because when
it was approved on a backboard you have
like less contributions like it feels
like I'm doing something that is not
much people doing right so it was there
again it was really a feeling of
accomplishment right because you know
millions of people Google Microsoft
every big company has something working
with node.js react or everything and now
your name has been written there even
though it wasn't something that hard
right when when you look through this
solution you said no this is anyone
could do this but to go through the
whole process and to figure out the
solution this is something that we
developers we face every day right so
working on working on open source or for
companies that is not that different the
difference is actually uh test
management right this is the hardest
part
well
all of this talk is about node.js and
Community I'm not here to say no I'm
good I just fixed something no just no
everyone could do this right but when we
try to face a new challenge and when we
figure that people have the same
struggle that we have this is something
that changes everything right uh we were
talking right I flew from Brazil 30
hours from there and now I feel home
like I see people that has the same
struggles I have and this is really
amazing for everything and actually for
me like for all places I've been it's
exactly like a family right so this is
really really nice well because of these
things trying to help a lot I finally
got a nomination on the node.js so I was
actually contributing without anything
there like any one of you could do there
but now I could like review requests I
could like attend meetings trying to
join some working groups like I joined
now the working group of the node.js
tooling group to work on clis and a lot
of stuff there and you are getting even
more deeper right and learning a lot of
for a lot of people and this is funny
because the people that usually you
idolize right they have actually the
same questions like what is not working
here it's like I have no idea let's try
fixing it and let's try searching
together so we can find everything okay
well
I've been doing a lot of content about
node.js on my channel as well so
actually math science right so I
implemented the web socket from scratch
and I learned a lot of stuff so as I'm
saying when you challenge yourself when
something totally out of your comfort
zone this helps a lot to get other
contacts and even to make more money
right this is why we're here right to
switch jobs or to make even more money
on our jobs well I actually built a
whole textbook it's like a step by step
how I solve the problem so if you are
curious you can actually get the node.js
branch for there and do every step I did
until you reach the same result I did I
think this is a good experiment for you
who's curious or if you have any other
idea of how you could implement it right
nice well I'm actually I'm a full-time
content producer so I'm releasing uh
training cards right now about node.js
Stream So the most powerful uh tool
there so I'm Gonna Leave a link at the
end if you are gonna prior register but
this will be crazy and all the content
I've been doing it's already on my
website so everything is there if you
wanna take a look later study more right
try to find more topics to research
about you can go further there and get
uh these things all right
well
before I finish this talk I will leave
some five seconds for you to take a
picture to get these lights because you
know right this takes a long time to
build it
and why you take pictures well I have
five minutes so let's take a selfie
right oh let's make some noise
well on three We Make Some Noise all
right and we we jump the arms through to
there okay so one two three
oh
I really enjoyed this alright thank you
so much for having me